les vendangeurs sont à pied d'oeuvre
dans le sancerrois fixée au 3 octobre le
banc à dans certaines exploitations été
retardée pour cause de pluie c'est le
cas à ménétréol où la seule femme chef
d'exploitation du sancerrois a donné les
premiers coups de sécateurs aujourd'hui
david joya et daniel le floch étaient
présents grosse activité dans le
sancerrois ce milieu de semaine et une
pancarte attire le regard
bontemps et figuiers christine a pris la
succession de roger il ya sept ans c'est
la seule femme chef d'exploitation dans
le vignoble les parcelles ont souffert
cette année et la vigne est hétérogène
la réalisation du millésime 2001 sera
donc affaire de technique il faut pas
nouvelle et sucre et l'acidité ce soit
équilibré en fait cette année le
problème c'est que les acidités aucune a
chuté donc en fait tout va être là en
fait par derrière la vinification y aura
peut-être des fermentations
malolactiques à effectuer pour faire
chuter un petit peu les hostilités en
fait sous la direction de christine 20
ouvriers ramasse le rouge pendant six
jours les machines prendront le relais
pour le blanc six années d'études
un bts viticulture ont suffi à rassurer
roger bontems sur les capacités de sa
fille à reprendre ses huit hectares de
vignes dans un milieu toujours très
masculin je pense pas qu'il ya vraiment
des vingt-cinq mille hommes
en fait après faut savoir capter la fin
le client la tombe du client fait sans
changer son produit mais savoir enfin
travailler son produit pour obtenir ce
qu'en fait ils veulent donc en fait je
suis fier
j'ai pas me fier parce que c'est je
connais son caractère les commensaux
caractère assez vifs mais enfin à cesc
aveu je donne un petit conseil pour au
point de vue vigne mais au point de vue
cave se finit faux poète de patron pour
qualifier le millésime à venir je vous
livre en exclusivité ce qui se dit dans
les rangs ce moment même on a connu
mieux
on a connu pire